esta vez tenemos siete mil 329 menos
seis mil 278 haremos la resta de la
misma manera que lo hicimos en el vídeo
anterior haremos la separación o el
reagrupamiento por categoría de cada uno
de estos números para que podamos hacer
las restas de una manera ade y
entendamos la lógica de pedir prestado
de otras columnas vamos a separar este
primer número siete mil 329 esto es
igual a siete mil
+ 300 porque estamos en las centenas más
veinte o dos decenas más nueve unidades
mientras que 6.278 es igual a 6 unidades
de millar o 6000 más dos centenas o 200
más siete decenas
8 así tenemos la operación completamente
digamos qué desmenuzada categorizada o
reagrupada lo que haremos ahora es el
análisis que normalmente hacemos columna
por columna o categoría por categoría
que en este caso ya lo tenemos
desmenuzado 9 es más grande que 8 por lo
tanto será más sencillo tenemos un 20
que es más pequeño que 70 por lo que
ocuparemos a este 300 pedirle 100
unidades se convertirá en un 200
y este se convertirá en
cuidado y otra vez regreso al mismo
punto no estoy cambiando los números lo
que estoy haciendo es reagrupar los o
reordenar los de tal manera que ahora
podamos hacer esta resta 300 más 20 es
igual a 320 de la misma manera que 200
más 120 es igual a 320 se dan cuenta que
es exactamente lo mismo ahora este 200
al menos es igual que este 200 por lo
tanto podremos hacer la resta y 7000 sin
duda es más grande que 6000 vamos
entonces
columna por columna a hacer nuestras
operaciones
9 - 8 es igual a 1
120 ahora tenemos este 120 menos 70 es
igual a 50
200 menos 200 es igual a cero y 7000
6000 es igual a mil
hacemos una vez la suma de mil 050 más
uno va a ser un total de mil 51
vamos a ver de este lado cómo se hace de
una manera más rápida
9 - 8 sabemos que será 1 porque 9 es
mayor que 8 aquí tenemos el problema con
el 2 y con el 7 el 2 es más pequeño que
el 7 haremos lo siguiente pediremos
prestado al 3 que es la columna de las
centenas y lo convertiremos en un 2
este 2 va a prestarle uno a la columna
de las decenas y se convierte ahora en
un 12 recuerda que realmente lo que esto
significa es 12 decenas 12 monedas de 10
pesos es decir 120 pesos y este 2
equivale a 2 centenas o dos billetes de
100 200 pesos
de tal manera que tenemos 200 pesos más
120 320 vamos bien ahora tenemos 12
menos 7 es igual a 5
2 - 2 es igual a 0
y 7-6 es igual a 1 tenemos exactamente
el mismo número de aquí lo que es
importante y hago énfasis en ello es que
cada vez que ustedes vean por ejemplo
aquí un 2 sepan que están en la columna
de las centenas porque son unidades
decenas centenas y unidades de millar
realmente tenemos 200 pero este 2 se
representa aquí con un solo dígito
vamos claros espero que esto les vaya
dando muchísimo más claridad de cómo
funciona
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo